it's the latest chapter of the crypto
scammer who's probably headed to The
Slammer Sam bankman freed gets prison
advice he sorely needs FTX founder Sam
bankman freed is back at his parents
house as if in in California after being
released on a 250 million dollar Bond
you know the same deal that offer any
non-white criminal
yeah let that sink in
I guess they're not worried he'd jump
bail because that involves well jumping
laughs
he's a bag of oatmeal okay let's just be
honest
don't don't be polite now
and workers were spotted installing
security cameras outside the home near
the Stanford University campus if they
see him naked the cameras are programmed
to self-destruct
Bateman freed has to wear a cankle
Monitor and and can only leave the house
to get substance abuse treatments for
exercise which is something he's clearly
never done before
you know I'm just vicious tonight and
you don't usually see someone go to
rehab for eating Nutter Butters but
the good news is he's starting heroin
and is an excuse so he can get some
fresh air
meanwhile farmer bro Martin scurelli
remember him he gots him and he got some
advice for bankman freed shave your head
deepen your voice and start listening to
rap
the same advice I got from MC Dana
Perino
my advice for him includes uh deepening
his voice Sam is gonna have a lot of
issues because he's a bit of an
effeminate
guy people get the sense that they can
pick on you they will pick on you and
you know it's going to be very hard for
him to sort of adjust to that sort of
Lifestyle he should be listening to as
much rap music as possible he should be
trying to learn everything there is to
know about gangs about the tough
neighborhoods in every major city this
sounds funny but this could save your
life
any more advice my suggestion to him is
that he rebrands himself quite a bit in
fact he probably should no longer say
that he's from Stanford or something
like that he can say that he's from
Oakland and I think people would rather
hear him lie than hear the truth even if
they know it's a bit of a lie he should
probably start to reinvent his
background in history because the rich
white kid from a good neighborhood that
story doesn't sound great
[Laughter]
well the dude isn't wrong follow it
although anyone who thinks bankman freed
is from the streets must be drunk on the
toilet wine
and if he is listening to rap stay away
from Vanilla Ice
even the Aryan Brotherhood calls him too
white
for more on this I caught up with well
myself and bankman freed earlier today
Tyrus live Sam how are you getting ready
for the big house I've been playing
we can relate to the other prison guests
and I'm studying music with basses and
guitars to the Huckabee collection ain't
nobody give a damn about no Huckabee you
need to get your mind right shave your
head do some push-ups give me this
listen to some rap music be back in
three hours
[Music]
I can't draw that for you all right my
don't you ever
thank you
so back to me
[Applause]
all right I'll start with you Matthew
that riveting performance he think Sam
Bateman freed was given good advice for
prison I think it was good advice but
first I'd be remiss if I didn't comment
how Jack that guy is
what a house uh you know I I think
that's good advice you got to toughen up
your image although I was told during a
prison field trip in high school that I
would do very well in prison
an inmate interrupted his speech and he
said you'd be very popular here
so I'm
yeah yeah sure it wasn't your soft skin
and small muscle tone then
moisturize do you like Kool-Aid as lip
gloss no anyway all right Michelle is it
fair that Sam was released on 250
million dollar Bond nothing about this
story is fair and I have this every time
I hear sandbankment of freed I feel like
this guy's gonna skate I feel like this
guy might just get away with this I
don't know why because there's like this
two-tiered system of justice you know
I'm still pissed that Lois Lerner isn't
Behind Bars I'm still angry that Hillary
Clinton got away with all their emails
but um it feels like this guy because of
his Stanford connections and all that
good advice he just got may just walk
away unscathed I don't know I mean it's
a massive crime in I guess 115 years
behind bars is the potential sentence
but I I just I have this awful feeling
that like in all these interviews he's
gonna sit in front of the jury and say
you know I was just so busy I just was
busy and you know I had to comb my hair
a lot so I couldn't keep track of
everything that was going on so I I
that's none of this is fair none of it's
right Joe you're from the streets when
you when you when you look when you look
at this whole situation
he's a do you think because he's been a
I guess the upper class criminal that
he's going to be able to Swerve his way
through the prison hierarchy and
convince everyone to invest in him not
physically look he he was given the best
piece of prison advice don't tell him
you live in Stanford
that's the best advice don't don't do
that you want to tell them when they see
you say something like tell them you
went to Brown yeah no don't don't let
them know tell me you went to Columbia
for God's sake these are hardened
criminals here how do you want to pen if
you want to live but you have to say I
don't know if that advice is is good uh
notwithstanding the performance of King
Kong Bundy over here
not I don't think I do on the inside uh
I'm not doing great on the outside
it could be fair yeah all right well we
do have a doctor on the show so I would
be remiss not to ask a medical question
doctor uh in your professional opinion
which Joe would do better in prison
put them together and they both are
winners oh look at that uh first of all
Tyrus did you you skimmed over the part
where they said he's at house arrest but
he can leave the house for exercise and
mental health treatment that's better
than non-criminal Americans were treated
throughout our lockdowns gyms were
closed you couldn't leave your house all
mental health went completely remote and
online so he's getting the Royal
Treatment as far as I'm concerned and
then you have Martin shkreli the guy who
price gouged life-saving medications
just to make a quick Buck because he
could do it that's who's giving him
advice I mean these two kids are
disgusting and they are a poor
representation of this entire generation
who are all about a quick buck and they
don't care who they step on along the
way I think he was giving that advice in
case they were in the same jail so he
would be more favored than he would be
maybe yeah I think I think I think you'd
survive on the inside a little bit
better but hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
says you will not get it anywhere else